last sorry to interrupt but literally in
the last 60 seconds that you've been
talking michelle barnier has actually
tweeted and i have to say
it's not hugely positive let me just
tell you what he says we agreed
to pause the talks in order to brief our
principles on the state of play of the
negotiations president wonderland and
prime minister johnson will discuss the
state of play
tomorrow afternoon as you can see on the
screen actually he also tweeted after
one week of intense negotiations in
london
together with david frost we agreed
today that the conditions
for an agreement are not met due to
significant
divergences on level playing field
governance
and fisheries so adam still
a long way from agreement it would seem
tonight that's really important
because what he is effectively saying is
that
my reading with that would be that
michelle barnier who has a mandate
a set effectively a set of instructions
about how far he can go
is almost raising a white flag and
saying i can't go any further within the
strictures that are in place
now this has been talked about over the
past 48 hours i think both in the uk
uh and and here in brussels as being the
only way out of this
could be for uh ursula von de line the
boss of the european commission to get
on the phone to boris johnson
and thrash things out person to person
and those three things that you just
outlined there are the three sticking
blocks we've had before
we just run through fisheries uh that
the uk
does not want to allow europe in fishing
boats in
into its waters in any substantial
numbers the european union says that is
outrageous
level playing field this is the in a
sense for some people's idea that the
the essence of sovereignty is to try to
flex different rules the eu says that
isn't
acceptable if you're going to enter the
single market governance is really about
how you
run this deal and those three things
have been talked about for months
if they haven't made progress on those
there won't be a deal
and i think what you're there is messes
barney and frost saying
we've gone as far as we can we need
concessions we need compromises
and the people who can do that are boris
johnson on the side of the uk
ursula from the line to an extent but
then that's really going to need
european leaders as well but to get to
this point
that is not a good sign that is not
an optimistic set of words uh for
michelle barnier
i mean frankly when you're pausing
negotiations with
less than a month to go before brexit
comes to an end
well you're a long long way from the
finishing line
okay adam in brussels thank you very
much well our deputy political editor
sam coates is with me
in the studio um as adam was saying
there
i mean it doesn't look good does it um
there was some hope for optimism in that
michelle barnier was going to stay
for the weekend talks were obviously
going to continue but what's your
reading of this uh
latest tweet so i think that
ultimately there was always going to be
a moment where boris johnson needed to
politically intervene in these talks the
british side have been saying that for
10 days
the eu side have signaled that even this
week
and this is it um there also needed to
be drama
there needed to be drama because britain
needs to have scored a victory
uh in the eyes of uh public opinion
uh in the final furlong of these talks
uh and that was quite hard uh given the
mandate that michelle
barnier uh set uh and was having to work
to set by
uh the eu uh 27. so while um so i
completely agree with adam it is not an
optimistic sign
that the uh principal negotiators cannot
uh strike a deal nevertheless uh i think
everybody
was expecting there having to be this
moment
where the most senior people involved in
the negotiation the head of the
commission
and the british prime minister actually
got involved got on the phone
in the progress uh to a deal um it was
expected yesterday
uh and here it is uh tonight you would
expect the the negotiations to be paused
while that took place there's not a lot
more that
uh mr barney and mr frost can do until
that conversation
has taken place there are understood to
be issues particularly around
just how you work out how the uk relates
the eu in terms of standards and laws
and rules
and the kind of consequences if uh one
side or the other moves away from any
agreement that's the biggest
sticking point i suspect at the moment
it needs to be dealt with
at the very highest level so we will get
better understanding of whether we're
heading to a deal or not heading to a
deal
i suspect after this call has taken
place yes it's